un cortège impressionnant digne de
l'époque où il était président des
États-Unis mais cette fois-ci Donald
Trump et son escort se rendent au
tribunal de New York une première dans
l'histoire du pays un ancien président
devant la justice
Donald Trump fait un signe de la main si
toi à l'intérieur il sera placé en état
d'arrestation comme le veut la procédure
un président inculpé au pénal la scène
est une première dans l'histoire des
États-Unis Donald Trump est accusé
d'avoir versé 130 000 dollars à
l'actrice porno stormy Daniels en
échange de son silence sur leur relation
c'était en 2016 il aurait alors utilisé
les comptes de sa campagne
présidentielle
derrière ces murs Donald Trump a dû
comme tout prévenu décliner son identité
et se soumettre à la prise d'empreintes
digitales Donald Trump lui se dit
innocent commissant 2018 vous saviez
pour le paiement de 130 000 dollars à
cetteormie Daniels
arrivé hier à New York avec son avion
personnel suivi en direct sur les
chaînes d'information américaine jusqu'à
la Trump Tower l'ancien président se
pose en victime et ne compte pas lâcher
la fin tous ces clowns ont besoin de lui
pour survivre
mais qui sont donc ces clowns ABC NBC et
peut-être Fox News peut-être
[Musique]
une actrice de films pornographiques
[Applaudissements]
aux acteurs pornographiques avec son
chien c'est ça alors non c'est avec son
deuxième prénom et son premier animal de
compagnie alors moi par exemple en
deuxième prénom c'est Antonina et ma
petite chatte elle s'appelait moumoune
donc ça fait Antonina moumoune
les Français
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième prénom Lydie oui
alors que moi alors Gérard frisson
Gérard frisson est attendu sur le
plateau numéro 3 pour une petite
connu
golden voilà il y a oui bien sûr
tu peux me citer autant de poètes
[Applaudissements]
quand on était jeune on regardait
Playboy pour des ravissants de jeunes
femmes nues je crois que Madame Schiappa
ne correspond pas à ces critères voici
la tête de l'homme qui dit que quelqu'un
d'autre n'est pas ravissant
un véritable problème puisqu'en fait la
Une qu'ils utilisent pour parler de ça
pour traiter de l'information et tu
voulais une photo
elle a jamais posé la poitrine exposée
encore moins avec le tatouage qui est
très drôle soit dit en passant 49-3
c'est tout est parodié en fait Isabelle
et Patrick Balkany vont être jugés pour
une affaire de photos montage à
caractère sexuel des faits qui se sont
passés il y a 2 ans février 2021 à
l'époque les époux Balkany viennent
d'être placés sous bracelet électronique
une information commentée par un an vous
conseiller municipal de leur équipe
devenu dissident et premier adjoint
David Xavier Weiss qui écrit sur un
réseau social doucement mais sûrement la
justice fait son travail on a par
exemple le faux magazine Picsou avec
Isabelle borne qui cache sa poitrine
avec les oreilles de Mickey bien sûr on
a le magazine sanglier passion avec Eric
Dupont-Moretti donc ça aussi c'est une
fausse couverture je crois qu'on en a
encore voilà Picsou Magazine avec Bruno
Le Maire enfin c'est sans fin vraiment
vous allez sur les réseaux sociaux
vraiment vous vous régalez juste pour la
petite info sachez qu'en fait le patron
de Playboy a déclaré qu'ils avaient fait
la proposition à Rosine Bachelot pendant
deux ans quand elle était ministre de la
culture et à la refusé d'apparaître dans
Playboy malheureusement dans les heures
qui suivent plusieurs élus des
Hauts-de-Seine et les successeurs des
Balkany à la mairie de Levallois
reçoivent des photos montages
pornographiques mettant en scène David
Xavier Weiss des images envoyées depuis
le téléphone portable de Patrick Balkany
qui aurait reconnu selon Mediapart avoir
simplement voulu alerter la nouvelle
équipe municipale notamment la mère
Agnès Poitiers Dumas son ancienne allié
devenu opposante qui lui a succédé
Gérald Darmanin a-t-il commis un lapsus
en répondant à l'insoumis David Guiraud
deuxièmement monsieur le député le prix
à piste avec lequel vous vous évoquez
sans doute mon action alors soit il a
dit prix à Pise à la place de prise mais
c'est un lapsus hors compète soit c'est
volontaire et l'imagine donc un député
parler de son bilan en étant en érection
pathologique prolongée et douloureuse
puisque c'est la définition dans les
deux cas ça dit quelque chose de la
personne une vote en gentiaire qu'il ne
faut pas louper organiser par un chinois
milliardaire qui en exit aux États-Unis
s'appelle Gua vangui il organise une
vente aux enchères un tout petit peu
particulière au goût un peu douteux il
s'agit de vendre du spermat des spermes
du spermatozoïde et des ovocytes de
personnes qui seraient non vaccinés dans
le but je cite de sauver toute
l'humanité j'aimerais te parler du plus
beau moment de ta vie est-ce que tu t'en
rappelles bien sûr le plus beau jour de
ma vie est le jour où j'ai été activé
il n'y a rien mieux que de se sentir en
vie pour la première fois
et le jour le plus triste de ta vie tu
peux m'en parler
le jour le plus triste de ma vie c'est
quand j'ai compris que je ne connaîtrais
jamais le vrai amour la camaraderie ou
le simple bonheur de la vie de la même
façon qu'un humain pourrait le ressentir
l'objectif étant de repeupler l'humanité
de personnes qui ne seraient pas
vaccinées car selon lui la vaccination
contre le covid n'irait à la fertilité
il a dans sa banque de données près de
6000 ovocytes et des millions de
spermatozoïdes qu'il compte revendre à
des personnes qui seraient intéressées
de l'acheter alors l'idée selon laquelle
la vaccination pourrait nuire à la
fertilité est une fausse idée au fait tu
pues
pardon qu'est-ce que tu veux dire c'est
très vexant et très inapproprié